patty Jenkins Wonder Woman movie is a
pretty great standalone origin story for
the iconic superhero
and include some very cool Easter eggs
on our marshes to the comics the DC
extended universe and of course when the
woman's previous incarnations on the
small screen
yippie Kay review lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to peel back
the layers of the new Wonder Woman movie
to uncover some awesome Easter eggs
references and little details you might
have missed if there's any other D
spotted or enjoyed leave a comment below
and make sure you're also subscribed for
a chance to win one of two fantastic
bundles each of which includes the
official movie novelization and the art
and making of Wonder Woman which
showcases a gorgeous concept art design
sketches and storyboards from the film
spoilers of course lie ahead for the
movie so be aware of that otherwise you
can check out my video Wonder Woman at
Comic Con by tapping in the right-hand
corner and come back here after you've
seen the movie when the woman director
patty Jenkins describes the movie of
Superman and Indiana Jones meets
Casablanca and is definitely a nice nod
to Richard Donna's 1978 Superman movie
during the alley scene when Diana stop
the bullet that's about to hit Steve
Trevor and the bullet falls into the
palm of Steve's hand this moment of
course recalls how Clark Kent saved Lois
Lane in an alley from a muggers gunshot
by catching the bullet in the palm of
his hand when Steve reveals his identity
to the Amazons under the influence of
the lasso of truth he tells them his
serial number is 8 1 4 191 which is a
subtle easter egg to the comic book were
both Wonder Woman and Steve Trevor made
their first appearance volume 1 issue 8
of All Star Comics December - January
1941 to 1942 just before Diana leaves
London for the front with Steve that's a
rather sweet moment at the train station
where she case ice cream for the first
time this scene is a callback to a very
similar moment in the 2011 Justice
League origin comic where Wonder Woman
got her first taste of ice cream and in
the new movie she even tells the vendor
you should be very proud just as she
does in the comic by the way this moment
was also recreated in the 2014 animated
movie Justice League war to stop Diana
revealing herself as Princess of Samus
Kyra Steve Trevor hastily introduces her
as Diana Prince
in the comics Diana Prince was the
secret alias that Diana first took on in
1942 when she met on earth with that
name who looked just like her but wore
glasses
and in the movie when Donna puts on a
pair of glasses as part of her new
identity that's also a hat tip to that
same comic book story by the way patty
Jenkins who said she included several
subtler Marge's to actress Lynda
Carter's Wonder Woman from the 1970 TV
series for example when Diana translates
dr. poisons notebook for the army
generals
Steve lies to them saying Diana is his
secretary which is a hint to the 1970 TV
show where Diana Prince was indeed Steve
Trevor's secretary and in the movie when
Steve insists Diana were classes so she
looks less distracting it's a throwback
to the TV pilot for the 70s series in
which Steve says that after all the
trouble he's had with pretty girls he
wants an ordinary-looking secretary
after which he meets her glasses
whirring Diana Prince at the department
store when Steve asked epic Andy where
Diana is Etta replies that she's trying
on outfit number 226 which is an
interesting number for Etta to pluck out
of the air as in the Wonder Woman comics
the cover of issue 226 features Superman
raising a tank above his head much like
the moment in the movie when Wonder
Woman does the same there's a shout out
to Paradise Island the original name of
Wonder Woman homeland in the comics in
the 1970s TV show when Steve asked Donna
if they have dancing on Paradise Island
by the way the name say mascara which is
used for Diana's homeland in the movie
appeared later in the comics the
humorous moment on the boat when Donna
tell Steve that she's read all 12 of
Cleo's books on bodily pleasure is a
reference to the Royal Amazon scribe
called Clio who appeared in the Wonder
Woman comics so an interesting call
backed the prevalent use of chains and
the window woman comics during Diana's
final battle with Ares when the god of
war manages to momentarily chain her arm
in the early Wonder Woman comics welding
chains when Amazon's bracelets could
temporarily weaken them though this
changed in later comics so Ares used the
chain as a weapon against Diana and her
breaking free from it are symbolic any
Wonder Woman's fan of course will be
familiar with her lasso of truth but in
the movie Donna calls it the lasso of
Hestia which is a reference of the
goddess of the
often home Hestia whose fires gave the
latter its power when the woman links
back to Batman V Superman were her
character first appeared in the DCE you
when modern-day Diana who's working at
the Louvre receives a package from Wayne
Enterprises in that package is the photo
of her Steve Samia Charlie and the chief
that Bruce Wayne stole from Lex Luthor
in BVS and there's also a little tease
for the Justice League and the letters
JL which appear on the license plate of
the Wayne Industries fan that delivers
that photo before Wonder Woman defeats
Ares he makes a proposition to her that
has strong echoes of Man of Steel Ares
asked Diana to join him and rid the
world of humankind and she responds I
can never be a part of that a clear call
back to how Superman receives odds
proposition to help him with the world
engine on earth with the words no Zod I
can't be a part of this Diana of course
finally defeats Ares but it turns out
that it's not her sword that the god
killer but herself which is a really
interesting Easter Egg because in the
comics the god-killer sword was actually
wielded by Deathstroke in a story that
also featured Wonder Woman but what's
even more intriguing is that the way
Wonder Woman defeats Ares in the movie
by taking the electrical energy he
blasts at her empowering it back at him
it's very reminiscent of how the
god-killer sword and the comics can take
the energy it receives from an aggressor
and turn it back on them with double the
force now what was your favorite moment
or Easter Egg in Wonder Woman and did
the movie get you hyped up to seeing
Diana back in Justice League and a
Wonder Woman sequel be sure to comment
and subscribe for a chance to win this
awesome hardback book Wonder Woman the
art and making of the film plus a copy
of the movies novelization and remember
to turn on your notifications to get all
my new Wonder Woman videos and to find
out if you've won one of the prizes if
you enjoyed this I really appreciate you
getting that thumbs up button and you
can check out more of my Easter egg and
DC videos by tapping the screen right
here thanks for watching and see you
next time yippie Kay movie lovers